Buon Giorno ciao
Stavo guardando dritto negli occhi
questo squalo di tre metri alle Hawaii solo
poche settimane fa e nello stesso modo in cui
puoi sentire qualcuno che ti fissa in modo inquietante
dall'altra parte della stanza ho potuto percepire
questo squalo che
sente ogni mio singolo movimento  Sono
sicuro che se avesse potuto percepire la mia paura mi sono
affermato per dimostrare che ero
curioso come lui in questa vasta
acqua blu intenso nella parte posteriore della mia testa, anche se
non potevo fare a meno di pensare che solo un
giorno fa un  il surfista aveva perso una gamba a
causa del morso di uno squalo tigre a meno di cinque
chilometri di distanza sì
e prima di salire a bordo della barca mi
sono tagliato accidentalmente un piede e stavo
sanguinando, quindi puoi immaginare la mia
esitazione a saltare
nell'acqua infestata dagli squali con oltre cento
metri di visibilità con nient'altro che una
GoPro in mano e un po' di attrezzatura per lo snorkeling, ma
è stata la mia insaziabile curiosità nel
desiderio di provare qualcosa di nuovo che
mi ha spinto a saltare dal lato di quella barca e
nell'ignoto Albert Einstein ha detto che è
meglio che non ho  sp  talenti speciali Sono solo
appassionatamente curiosa la
curiosità appassionata ci dà uno scopo e attraverso la
perseveranza coinvolge le persone a far
parte di un movimento collettivo è
semplice come ABC o nelle parole di mia madre
cosa sono un cinese nato in America ma
significa anche essere sempre curiosi c'era  uno
studio pubblicato nell'ottobre del 2014 che
suggerisce che la chimica del cervello
cambia effettivamente quando diventiamo curiosi
aiutandoci a imparare meglio e conservare le
informazioni
anche informazioni che non
intendevamo nemmeno conoscere uno dei coautori dello studio, il
dott.  Matthias Gruber spiega
che ciò è dovuto al fatto che la curiosità mette il
cervello in uno stato che gli consente di apprendere
e conservare qualsiasi tipo di informazione è
come un vortice che ti risucchia in ciò
che sei motivato a imparare, ma anche
tutto ciò che lo circonda l'apprendimento
crea dipendenza loro
-  questa materia grigia a forma di mandorla nel
lobo temporale del nostro cervello l'amigdala
l'amigdala rilascia dopamina che si
comporta come il pulsante di salvataggio naturale del cervello
spiega perché ci viene un ronzio
imparando qualcosa di nuovo la dopamina è così
importante per l'apprendimento e la ritenzione che
quando è  presente tendiamo a ricordare
un'esperienza o un messaggio ma quando è
assente nulla sembra attaccarsi sono un
giornalista investigativo un'emittente sportiva
e conduttrice televisiva sono anche un
girovago per il mondo ho iniziato a fare ricerche per il
mio lungometraggio documentario plastic paradise
dieci anni fa come  un progetto parallelo perché
ero solo curioso di sapere cosa
fosse mai questo Great Pacific Garbage Patch nei miei
sogni più sfrenati, avrei pensato che il
mio  la curiosità mi porterebbe lungo la strada
fino al punto in cui sono di fronte a tutti voi
oggi
Non volevo conoscere la storia
della plastica, la chimica dietro di essa o
come stavamo pagando il prezzo della sua
apparente usa e getta, davvero solo
non pensavo affatto alla plastica e
questa è la cosa che nessuno di noi pensa
alla quantità di plastica usa e getta che
usiamo ogni giorno perché è così prontamente
disponibile per noi ed è una
parte così onnipresente della nostra vita quotidiana ogni
singolo pezzo di plastica  che sia mai
stato creato
è ancora da qualche parte su questo pianeta
perché non è mai biodegradabile, è
letteralmente intessuto nel tessuto della nostra
vita attraverso tessuti come poliestere
e nylon e in ciò che facciamo e
mangiamo, nonché ricercatori recenti di settembre 2015
del  L'Università della
California-Davis ha scoperto che il 55% delle
specie di pesci campionate in Indonesia
conteneva detriti di origine umana con uno contenente
21 pezzi di plastica ora
questa immagine è in realtà da th  e Great
Pacific Garbage Patch
quando il ricercatore dr.  Marcus Erickson stava
viaggiando attraverso e ha catturato questo
corridore arcobaleno pensando che l'avrebbe
mangiato, ma invece ha trovato tutta questa plastica
al suo interno come un
appassionato surfista subacqueo e amante dell'oceano
Sono sempre stato affascinato dagli
oceani e da tutto ciò che contiene e  In un certo senso sono
caduto nell'esaminare l'inquinamento da plastica
semplicemente perché era nelle onde che
stavo surfando o quando facevo immersioni subacquee
sul fondo dell'oceano lo vedevo
ovunque e non erano solo le mie
spiagge domestiche, era ovunque in tutto
il mondo  in cui ho viaggiato Viaggiare è
una parte importante della mia vita ed è
qualcosa che ha definito e plasmato
Chi sono e non do
per scontate le opportunità che ho avuto mi ha aiutato ad
acquisire nuove prospettive e cerco sempre
di guardare  cose con un obiettivo diverso
per prendere la strada meno percorsa nelle mie
ambizioni di carriera oltre ad andare fuori
dai sentieri battuti che mi hanno portato in uno dei
luoghi più remoti del pianeta
nel mezzo del vasto Oceano Pacifico
dieci  A migliaia di chilometri di distanza
da qualsiasi civiltà si trova questo minuscolo
pezzo di terra Atollo di Midway,
questo 2,4 miglia quadrate di terra era
parte integrante della storia della seconda guerra mondiale poiché
la battaglia di Midway fu un punto di svolta
per le forze alleate fu anche una
svolta  punto in Revelation per me poiché la mia
curiosità mi ha portato a uno scopo viaggiando
ora in un rifugio della marina nazionale e sede
di 1,5 milioni di uccelli albatri Laysan in
questo bellissimo paradiso apparentemente incontaminato e incontaminato,
ho visto in prima persona le
ripercussioni del nostro uso di plastica usa e getta
non solo lavato via  lungo le rive
e nella sabbia ma anche nel ventre
di questi uccelli che avrebbero scambiato questa
plastica per cibo e l'avrebbero mangiata e
sarebbero stati letteralmente riempiti e soffocati con questa
plastica la mia amigdala stava lavorando per
sovraccarico, in altre parole la mia mente era
sbalordita ora potevo  ho messo online questo potente
filmato nel 2009 quando lo abbiamo girato
e probabilmente sarebbe diventato virale
perché non era mai stato visto prima, ma la
storia più ampia era sti  tutto si sta svolgendo e
non volevo condividere queste informazioni
prematuramente come emittente sportiva e
conduttrice televisiva, mi occupo di eventi sportivi e
rapporti sulla vita e le storie di altre persone
e con il passare degli anni in questo progetto,
anche se sono diventata organicamente parte della
narrativa e  questo è stato un percorso completamente nuovo
inesplorato Mi considero un
attivista accidentale Mi piace la maggior parte di noi
solo che non ho mai pensato alla
plastica perché voglio dire che era proprio lì
nello stesso modo in cui non ti
accorgi di quanto siamo legati ai nostri
gadget  ed elettronica o forse
apatico per le questioni sociali, politiche e
ambientali perché a volte
è semplicemente troppo insormontabile chiudere un
occhio è molto più facile la curiosità ha
ucciso il gatto qualcuno potrebbe dire ma la mia
appassionata curiosità mi ha aiutato a trovare uno
scopo da seguire e a condividere storie
non raccontate  immergermi letteralmente sotto la superficie
in questo caso quando ho
iniziato a conoscere gli oceani non
sapevo davvero cosa stavo facendo, mea  n
Avevo ospitato e prodotto
contenuti in forma breve e sai che non era niente di
questa portata o intensità il mio
percorso professionale non è mai stato chiaramente segnato
e sono stato in grado di passare dal
reportage sportivo alla presentazione TV fino anche a un
po' di recitazione.  'ho sempre
voluto comunicare e raccontare grandi
storie e usare il potere dei media
per il bene e per raggiungere un nuovo pubblico
ed esporre la verità, ho capito che
con il senno di poi essere il
tuttofare mi ha permesso di avere
molteplici  prospettive in cui vedere
il mondo e quando finalmente avrò accettato il
fatto che ero il tuttofare
e il maestro di nessuno potevo andare avanti
con la sicurezza e la libertà di fallire
sì è
quello che ho detto che potevo andare avanti  con
la sicurezza e la libertà di
fallire in realtà è abbastanza liberatorio ed è
stato solo un piccolo cambiamento di prospettiva
che ha fatto la differenza abbracciare il
tuo io autentico imperfettamente perfetto i
bambini sono veramente autentici che hai mai
notato  it un bambino fa i capricci e di
solito si tratta di qualcosa di completamente
insignificante, ma per loro qualunque
cosa stia piangendo è la cosa più
importante
al mondo in quel momento, il
blogger autore e papà casalingo Greg
Pembroke ha compilato tutto  questi
motivi illogici per cui i bambini piangono, incluso lui
non riesce a trovare la sua paperella di gomma o
continua a far cadere la sua forchetta ed eccone
uno preferito hanno nuovi cappelli i bambini sono
davvero accattivanti con la loro
innocenza con gli occhi spalancati che sembra scomparire lentamente
man mano che cresciamo  più grandicelli sono i loro veri
piccoli sé autentici e
piangono per le minuzie della vita quotidiana
anche quando tuo padre rompe il formaggio a
metà Io insegnavo lezioni di surf e
insieme alla miriade di altri lavori quando
ero un aspirante giornalista e ho
sempre  amavano insegnare ai bambini perché
hanno questa innata impavidità che agli
adulti sembra mancare non avevano
preconcetti non avevano
problemi
e si limitavano a provare  e hanno provato
senza esitazione e la maggior parte delle volte
non sarebbero riusciti a stare in piedi su quell'onda
ma sarebbero andati a remare su
quella tavola di nuovo tra le onde e
provare e riprovare la definizione di
perseveranza è questo persistere
fermamente nell'inseguimento  di un'impresa
un compito un viaggio o una meta anche se
ostacolato da distrazioni difficoltà
ostacoli o scoraggiamento mio papà
mi raccontava una storia su come ha conosciuto mia
mamma e il suo motto era sempre la tenacia
è la chiave è proprio quello che ha raccontato a mio
fratello come  alcuni consigli per avvicinare le
ragazze usano la persistenza e lui
aspetterebbe mia madre dopo la scuola e la accompagnerebbe a
casa fatto amicizia con la sua famiglia e i
suoi fratelli e usciamo semplicemente nelle
vicinanze generali in cui si troverebbe
e per la maggior parte la sua persistenza sarebbe
fraintesa  come inquietante o stalker, ma
guardalo, è super nerd, intendo in
un modo asiatico di Steve Urkel, che
è quello che direbbe bene un giorno mia madre
stava giocando con i suoi fratelli e
lei  ll e le si è rotta la clavicola e quindi
era in ospedale e mio padre sarebbe
andato a trovarla e le avrebbe portato fiori e riviste e sarebbe semplicemente passato del tempo con lei e
quello è stato il punto di svolta su come l'ha conquistata
e sul fatto che lei potesse'  t
davvero lasciare di nuovo la
persistenza è la chiave del mio diritto testardo
e come un classico figlio di mezzo che
muore per essere visto o ascoltato, le parole di mio padre hanno
colpito me e anche la sua
altra saggia saggezza e consiglio che
sarebbe andato con noi prima di
morire  di cancro avevo 17 anni ed era
dopo il primo anno di università e
mi ha davvero colpito la sua
scomparsa è stato un duro promemoria di come la vita
è breve e abbracciare ogni momento
pienamente per il presente è un dono ed è allora
che ho iniziato  viaggiando ogni
momento libero che ho avuto, quindi eccomi qui che mi trovo
appassionatamente curioso
di questo strano nuovo argomento, ma come
posso convincere le persone a occuparsene? Il
business che faccio nel settore dei media
è spietato, critico e
non è una novità, ma ho scoperto
che essere aperti e vulnerabili è la
chiave per coinvolgere le persone in connessioni autentiche reali. Una
volta mi sono state dette
alcune parole sagge da un
insegnante di giornalismo televisivo al liceo, ha
detto che più sei aperto e onesto
con le persone, più  onesto e
aperto saranno con te e lui lo ha detto
nel contesto di intervistare qualcuno
e tu sai che per farli sentire a proprio
agio e ottenere la loro fiducia racconta
loro qualcosa di te più
sei aperto e onesto con le persone
più sono oneste e aperte  sarò con
te Lo dico con la piena
consapevolezza che, come la maggior parte di noi, si
impegna attraverso i nostri telefoni, i nostri social
media e computer è così che mi
impegno anche io e nell'era digitale
tendiamo a condividere eccessivamente le nostre vite online
ma  in realtà in realtà è solo
la percezione e la facciata di una
sequenza temporale spesso meticolosamente curata
di eventi della vita di solito questi post sono
costituiti da cibo o cibo perfettamente posizionato
forse sono abiti accuratamente disposti
o la casualità artigianale della vita, ma
cosa accadrebbe se tirassimo indietro quella
foto quadrata 8 x 8 e guardassimo il
quadro più ampio di come saranno le nostre vite davvero
favolose ed eccitanti come sembra se
fossimo veramente aperti  e onesti l'uno con l'
altro non capita spesso che qualcuno
condivida qualcosa di profondamente personale o una
lotta sui propri social media e
sai che alzi gli occhi al cielo verso le persone
che lo fanno perché semplicemente non lo
fai non aderisce a un'etichetta sociale non detta
online  semplicemente non lo
condividi e forse è perché ci
sfugge qualcosa e non vogliamo
essere coinvolti troppo o in profondità avere quella
vera connessione ci vuole molto lavoro
il fatto che scriviamo più messaggi di quanto parliamo
in circa 97  La % dei bambini di età inferiore a 1 anno
ha utilizzato un computer o un dispositivo mobile
dovrebbe suonare un allarme il vero
coinvolgimento è difficile perché l'empatia è
davvero sentire ciò che l'altra persona sta
provando e la vera empatia è la forma più pura
di autenticità e connessione  zione quando
si è veramente impegnati con le persone
è qui che le collaborazioni funzionano e si formano e il
lavoro di squadra fiorisce e il cambiamento avviene
si parla molto di questa
pulizia del Great Pacific Garbage
Patch, ma molti di questi sforzi sono da
piccola a costosi e spesso
troppo rischioso per la vita oceanica, è ancora
essenzialmente un cerotto sul problema più grande
della nostra plastica monouso e di
cosa ne stiamo facendo, quindi ho
chiesto alle persone di impegnarsi a
dire di no alla plastica monouso per due
settimane dopo il mio  film e questo significa niente
bottiglie niente uso di cannucce niente utensili
niente da asporto praticamente niente
plastica usa e getta monouso per due settimane ed
è in realtà piuttosto difficile e non
avrei mai immaginato che l'impatto collettivo di un
impegno di questo impegno sarà di così
vasta portata come  una scintilla di
appassionata curiosità ha portato migliaia di
persone in tutto il mondo a
impegnarsi collettivamente tra loro e a connettersi
per fare qualcosa di così immediato e
tangibile per me  è stato stimolante ascoltare
storie individuali di come la vita delle persone
è cambiata facendo qualcosa
ogni giorno qualcosa di piccolo ogni giorno
e mi incoraggia a perseverare proprio come
mio padre
ogni interazione che abbiamo l'uno con l'
altro è un'opportunità per connetterci
e incoraggiare il cambiamento uno  delle mie
citazioni preferite è questo un viaggio di mille
miglia inizia con un solo passo che
fissa uno squalo negli occhi nell'oceano
quel giorno ha acceso la mia curiosità di
scendere da quella barca e in acque sconosciute
ed è una frazione di quanto sia spaventoso
stare a guardare davanti a tutti voi
spero che qualcosa che avete sentito oggi
accenda la vostra curiosità di portarvi a nuove
profondità e nuove esperienze che
non avreste mai immaginato idropisia un